LUKE MAHE: Ready to go.
So welcome to this Hangout.
This is the Places
API Hangout.
I am Luke Mahe and
this is Justin.
Justin is one of our PMs
down here in Sydney
on the Places team.
Justin, why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
JUSTIN CHU: Sure.
Thank you, Luke.
I was born and raised in
the States, New Jersey.
Moved out to California
to go to university.
I started off my Google career
last October at YouTube,
working on a bunch
of partner stuff.
But thankfully, I've been lucky
enough to come down to
this gorgeous city of Sydney,
Australia, and work with the
geo developer team and
the Maps API team
with Luke as well.
LUKE MAHE: Yes.
So we've got a special
day today with us
with the Base's API.
We're going to talk about a
couple of things which we're
launching very soon and then
maybe some stuff that's coming
down in the future.
JUSTIN CHU: Absolutely.
LUKE MAHE: So what've we got
to show people today?
JUSTIN CHU: Sure.
So today I'd like to talk about
a couple new things that
you just said, one of which
we call the JavaScript
Autocomplete Data Services.
And though that name is quite
a mouthful, it's actually
quite a straightforward, awesome
feature that we have.
So today in the JavaScript
library, you have to bind a
input field to some widget for
you to actually get the
autocomplete functionality.
That's pretty cool and fun.
That's pretty simple, so that a
lot of developers, they want
a quick easy fix, snap that
thing around to the
application, you get some
autocomplete functionality.
But obviously, Google
developers, externally and
internally, they want some more
flexibility and freedom.
And so with this JSON collection
from the data
service, you can style your
predictions in more
feature-rich ways.
And you can also add in your
own predictions as well.
So one use case, actually, that
Google uses themselves in
the Maps application is to put
in your home address with your
directions.
So as you can imagine during
location-based applications,
start locations, or important
locations, or things that you
need to know that you have in
your prediction list, you can
stick them right in there
alongside our
predictions as well.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
We actually have
a demo of this.
JUSTIN CHU: Awesome.
LUKE MAHE: So here we go.
So here we go.
Do you want to have a
play with your demo?
JUSTIN CHU: Sure, exactly.
So this demo is actually just to
showcase the styling things
that we can do today.
So with this new data service,
you can do things like
actually add different types of
color for flair that match
your applications themes.
This one, for example, is based
on the Google colors.
The fun thing here is that you
can actually-- it actually
rotates through different
colors through our log.
But you can do much stronger
things here, too, involving
premiere CSS and styling that
I know nothing about and
you're very, very good at.
So hopefully we'll get some cool
demos up in the future.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
Here we're just doing some cool
things by changing the
bold color to different--
JUSTIN CHU: Exactly.
LUKE MAHE: --interesting
colors to
highlight what was typed.
JUSTIN CHU: For sure, yeah.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
So what else have we got
coming out soon?
JUSTIN CHU: Yeah.
So this one's super exciting.
We call it the Query
Autocomplete.
And so when the Places API
launched last year, the
autocomplete functionality
was one of the most
differentiating, powerful
traits we had
as part of the service.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
I remember you do cool stuff
like just start typing where
you live, and it completed
your home address.
JUSTIN CHU: Exactly.
Pretty neat.
LUKE MAHE: It was so useful.
I remember the previous PM, Tor,
was obsessed with making
this the standard
for everybody.
He never wanted to every
type his address again.
He wanted to type the first
letter and then have all the
forms in the web complete
everything for him.
JUSTIN CHU: Yeah, that's a
perfect world, definitely.
And we're slowly
getting there.
I mean, there's more and more
people that are using the
service, for sure.
We also know that it's
not complete.
We were missing one big thing.
And that one big thing, we're
happy to say, we're including
today as our next [? update ?]
very soon.
Oh man.
It is going to be
popular queries.
So you can actually imagine
taking some of the magic of
that really cool, awesome search
box, map.google.com,
and putting that within
your own application.
So now, today, instead of saying
things like points of
interest, like Starbucks, or
addresses, like 48 Pirrama
Road, you can actually include
popular queries-- like Italian
restaurants, like
coffee shops--
inside the actual search
boxes themselves.
And things will get
autocompleted there.
LUKE MAHE: That's cool.
But I don't believe you.
So let's see a demo.
JUSTIN CHU: Cool.
So this is the gorgeous city
of Sydney, Australia.
I'm going to type in one of the
queries I have planned.
It's Italian restaurants, as
you can see, that rows two
through five, actually
have places
in geographic locations.
But the first one that was
autocompleted was actually a
query, Italian restaurants.
In case you don't believe me,
Luke, come up with a random--
what's a random query
we can think about?
LUKE MAHE: Oh, French
restaurants.
JUSTIN CHU: French?
No way.
Let's see if we can do it.
I see France coming
up, then food.
French, let's see.
Oh, restaurant, right there.
LUKE MAHE: Oh!
And you only had to type
in half of it.
JUSTIN CHU: Exactly.
Now that is what I called
good [INAUDIBLE].
LUKE MAHE: I know.
You've made my day.
JUSTIN CHU: And mine, too.
Oh my god.
Together, two days were made.
But yeah, so as you see in this
demo, which was awesome,
made by Luke and Co., you can
get cool queries and use them
alongside our other services
like text search and things
like that to get points of
interest on your map.
LUKE MAHE: And the very famous
one is pizza in New York.
You actually want to search for
pizza places in New York,
not just places that have "New
York pizza" in their name.
JUSTIN CHU: Oh, really?
How is the pizza
here in Sydney?
LUKE MAHE: Not as good
as New York.
JUSTIN CHU: Not as good,
you would say?
LUKE MAHE: I would say so from
personal experience.
JUSTIN CHU: So what's their
pride and joy, then?
What would be pizza in New York
to "blank" in Sydney?
LUKE MAHE: Oh, who knows?
You'd probably say the
traditional Aussie pie.
JUSTIN CHU: Aussie pie?
Good.
OK.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah.
JUSTIN CHU: I actually only
had that a couple times.
Is there such a thing
as tiger pie?
I heard of that.
LUKE MAHE: I think you're
making things up.
JUSTIN CHU: Oh.
And probably I've been
having bad sources.
But yeah, cool.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
So what are some other things
that are coming down the
pipeline for the Places API?
JUSTIN CHU: Well, so two
things I can call out
specifically, which I'm excited
about, one of which is
very much-- and thanks to the
people who have used our Issue
Tracker and Stack Overflow
and those forums--
that is, of course, Business
Listing Photos.
That is something we're very
actively working on and we're
excited to get out by
the end of the year.
Any questions for Photos?
LUKE MAHE: No.
JUSTIN CHU: Yeah.
It's exciting, though.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, it
is pretty cool.
JUSTIN CHU: Finally you can
get some pictures of what
you're looking at.
Next up by the end of the year
as well, is the thing that
we're going to call radar search
Essentially, you're
going to be able to get up to
200 lat/longs and references
of places around a
circular area.
So you can imagine that sort
of wave [INAUDIBLE]
coming out from you.
LUKE MAHE: That's cool.
JUSTIN CHU: And so this thing
here is basically a great--
one use case for it would be
building a heat map for the
neighborhood, trying to find
different types of avenues and
venues around where you live.
But besides that, it's a good
way to showcase the amount and
variety of places just
anywhere you want.
So it's not something about
specific details for a place,
but just what is the place
ecosystem around you like.
And I think it's really
interesting and definitely
visually very, very pretty.
LUKE MAHE: That's pretty cool.
There's a lot of useful use
cases for doing the what's
around me sort of queries.
JUSTIN CHU: Yes, completely.
And so in a little bit longer
term, there are two main
strengths that Places API have
that are guiding its road map.
The first one I can call out
is-- it's awesome data.
We have over 95 million points
of interest, amazing amounts
of telephone numbers, opening
hours, things like that that
we can share with people.
So how do we take that huge
amount of data and let
developers play with it more?
The specifics there are
still up in the air.
We're still definitely
[? designing some ?] things
out, but that's definitely a
theme you want to focus on,
taking that huge pile of data
we've got Google-scale and
making it available
to everybody.
Another piece is obviously the
suite of Google products we
have around us.
In the same building as us right
now, we have the Maps
API teams as well.
All the way across the Pacific
and California, obviously, we
have the Google+ team.
But these are services.
And they have APIs themselves
that we definitely want to
integrate well with.
And they'll go on and make these
summed-up the products
bigger and better than
individual pieces.
LUKE MAHE: So if Tor wanted to
see everybody using this
autocomplete to type in an
address, what do you want to
our developers do with
the Places APIs?
What are some cool things
you want people to do?
JUSTIN CHU: Absolutely.
I think that right now
there has been--
I'd be really interested
in seeing where the
location-based application
trends are going.
So for example, I thought it
was really interesting that
for the gaming companies that
were used to doing just
check-in-based games,
commerce-like games, now it's
very much actually purely a
zombie game, where you're
actually in the world,
more of a virtual
reality type of thing.
I think that not just in
location-based games, but just
in location-based apps
everywhere-- travel, social
networking, food and wine--
there's a lot of room to do
something above just the
baseline location data.
But you need the best data to
get the best services, right?
So that's why we're here.
LUKE MAHE: Yeah, true.
it would be cool to see people
actually get the data that we
provide and make some sense out
of it and offer something
more to the user than just, hey,
look at all those coffee
shops around you.
JUSTIN CHU: For sure.
Yeah, that's the goal.
So I don't have a specific
end point, I
guess, like Tor mentioned.
But as we get more and more
stuff out and see more and
more ideas, I bet I'll get
some better opinions too.
LUKE MAHE: Cool.
Well, that was short
and sweet.
Do you have any parting
words for everybody?
JUSTIN CHU: Yeah.
Well, first, thank you
so much for hosting.
It was a great experience.
LUKE MAHE: No problem We hope
we'll see you soon.
JUSTIN CHU: Oh, definitely And
on top of that, please check
out our Places API challenge.
It's located at developers.googl
e.com/places/challenge.
And you essentially get to build
an awesome application
to help your community out and
possibly win a chance to go to
I/O.
LUKE MAHE: And you get
to hang out with us.
JUSTIN CHU: Absolutely.
And who could ever
turn that down?
LUKE MAHE: No, exactly.
JUSTIN CHU: But thank you
guys for tuning in.
LUKE MAHE: Thanks, guys.